crise du porc crise du lait et en 2016
une moisson catastrophique pour les
céréaliers
cela fait plusieurs années que
l'agriculture française est au plus mal
ces derniers mois les manifestations se
sont multipliées agriculteurs un métier
sous tension la raison les prix qui leur
sont payés ne couvrent pas leurs coûts
de production
pourtant certains jeunes veulent croire
encore à un avenir dans le monde
agricole
nous avons voulu savoir pourquoi et
comment il voyait l'agriculture de
demain
[Applaudissements]
c'est celle qui font les concours
connaît les noms premier jour des
vacances scolaires pour antoine jaffray
à 16 ans il est en apprentissage au
lycée agricole de bourges c'est ça vous
embête me laisser passer
merci dès qu'il peut il rentrer à la
ferme familiale pour s'occuper de ses
filles comme il dit comprenez de ses
vaches
moi je préfère me passais mes journées
ici et pas forcément faire des grasses
matinées le matin même si pourtant les
grasses matinées au plus tard savez
twitter donc c'est plus agréable de
venir ici pendant les vacances que de
rester à la maison en rien faire soigner
son troupeau le nourrir le métier
d'éleveur et exigent un métier où l'on
ne compte pas ses heures de travail
mais cela ne fait pas peur au jeune
homme au contraire parce que on a une
approche et que les animaux et c'est
quelque chose que qui fait plaisir dans
son métier parce que dette avec les
bêtes au quotidien des bêtes qui vont
venir qui vous reconnaissent donc il
s'approche de vous qui se laisse
caresser et qu'on plaisir à venir vous
voir et puis des bêtes aussi comme don
quand on fait des vêlages le plaisir
donné naissance à des petits animaux
et justement ce matin l'une des génisses
et en grande difficulté elle est censée
mettre bas depuis plusieurs jours mais
antoine ne voit rien venir
il est inquiet elle en fait le volet
policier comme ça la situation est
critique
il est urgent de repositionner le veau
dans le ventre de la génisse sinon ils
risquent de mourir
parce que le jeu le remplacer ce
physique et ça ici duo mais c'est
physique frédéric chassot décide
d'appeler le vétérinaire
le père d'antoine a subi une opération
récemment il ne peut pas effectuer la
manoeuvre après plusieurs minutes
d'effort antoine parvient à replacer le
veau la génisse va enfin pouvoir mettre
bas frédéric c'est bien ce qu'il a fait
là encore oui c'est bien quand il arrive
à faire ça il va faire beaucoup de
choses
ce que replacer un veau c'est pas
évident dans le monde de la vache
surtout qu'il doit à ses goûts donc
lorsqu'il a fait c'est très bien en
principe il faut quelques années
d'expérience pour y arriver
[Musique]
chaque village est différent ces jeux
mais le même le dernier match que j'ai
fait j'ai fait des jumeaux ça s'est
mieux passé et il y avait qu un seul mot
c'était plus compliqué parce que tu es
sur le dos dont fait leur tournée je
pense que je vais encore jamais fait
c'était tout nouveau pour moi j'ai
réussi ça va je suis content mais oui
ils sont tous différents et tout d
émotion particulière différente et sa
passion des bovins antoine la tient de
son père un père particulièrement fiers
ce matin là pourtant frédéric a mis son
fils en garde quant à la difficulté du
métier
quand il m'a dit la première fois il
était encore très jeune donc j'ai dit
inquiète la folle toi pas faux réfléchis
voit autre chose il ya plein d'autres
choses qui te plaisent et mais non il
était il est fixé sur le sur le métier
et aujourd'hui je vois pas faire autre
chose que le métier d'éleveur
j'ai connu les bonnes années de la
guerre de l'élevage depuis 4 5 ans et
une bérézina pas possible c'est encore
pire cette année que les années
précédentes on a le climat qui s'est mis
de la partie il ya rien qui se vend en
objet de de repenser notre métier et se
remettent en cause quotidiennement et de
retravailler directement en vente
directe et pour arriver à s'en sortir
mais vous montrent toutes les factures
que j'ai ap voilà en gros livre de son
métier
une difficulté que connaît bien basile
faucheuse à 26 ans il était à la tête
d'une ferme de 160 hectares entre le
loiret et le loir et cher
il s'est installé en 2014
aujourd'hui on est en train d'arracher
du plan de pommes de terre qui servira
mes collègues
en france et dans le monde entier à hao
rose
refaire des pommes de terre y'a pas que
l'agriculteur qui vit de son métier à
savoir que pour un agriculteur et à 7
personnes qui travaillent à côté de lui
quand l'agriculteur va mal
tout le monde va mal sur ses cinq frères
et soeurs base il est le seul à avoir
repris l'exploitation familiale
je suis allé par passion et pas par
besoin ou nécessité je pense que si on
rentre pas agriculteur par passion on
n'y sera pas jusqu'au bout de sa vie
depuis qu'il a commencé sa jeune
carrière
basile a déjà subi trois crises
successives mais pas question pour lui
de jeter l'épongé
la crise c'est pas forcément ce à quoi
on s'attend quand on s'installe
agriculteurs j'ai depuis je suis
installé oui j'ai fait une très mauvaise
année une bonne et une très mauvaise
donc j'espère qu'un jour ça va être un
peu plus lisse que ça mais voilà c'est
la vie la nature est fait pour qu'on
s'en sorte à la elle nous donne toutes
les clés faut juste arriver à tout
exploité dans un contexte de couple
entre la nature et d'agriculteurs dans
un couple tout se passe pas toujours
tout n'est pas toujours très rose mais
on tend vers un avenir meilleur et
j'espère que c'est ce qui va se passer
l'avenir qu'en pense la nouvelle
génération comment voit-elle
l'agriculteur de demain dans ce centre
de formation par apprentissage agricole
les effectifs étaient en baisse ces
trois dernières années mais en 2015
l'établissement a vu ses classes se
remplir grâce notamment au plan
gouvernemental de relance de
l'apprentissage
ici un élève sur deux et fils ou fille
d'agriculteur ils ont entre 17 et 20 ans
cette année on a des qualités de blé dur
qui sont catastrophiques qu'on a aucun
blé dur qui passe en utilisation blé dur
classique c'est-à-dire pour faire des
pâtes etc
aucun lot qui passe la pluie ce n'est
pas le seul facteur qui explique cette
maladie à d'autres ont mis en avant mais
c'est un stade qui est très critique
cours d'agronomie le sujet du jour les
raisons de la terrible moisson de l'été
2016 bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
votre journal régional édition spéciale
consacrée aux intempéries
en quatre jours il est tombé
l'équivalent de deux mois de pluie
beaucoup de secteurs restent inondées
pour être sec et cette année on a eu
pendant toute cette période le temps le
plus humide qui soit ces intempéries du
mois de mai ont décimé les cultures
la perte pour les agriculteurs est
estimé à un milliard deux cents millions
d'euros rien qu'en centre val de loire
alors à la rentrée les élèves de
stéphane prochasson sont arrivés avec
beaucoup de questions et la tête pleine
de doutes pour l'avenir il a fallu les
rassurer
le but c'est pas de faire du
catastrophisme ans le but c'est de
regarder des choses avec maximum
d'objectivité l'important c'est que
partiellement ils ont compris pourquoi
il ya eu cette année catastrophique
bon bah d'essayer de mettre en avant le
trouver des solutions pour pour ce genre
de situation le j'ai remué à l'avenir
par exemple l'assurance climatique
il ya aujourd'hui
à ma connaissance que trois agriculteurs
sur dix qui seront assurées climatique
voilà je pense que une année comme cette
année des futurs installés ils vont
réfléchira à deux fois pour s'assurer ne
pas s'assurer par exemple on avait plus
si les agriculteurs n'ont jamais été
autant diplômés qu'aujourd'hui à côté de
l'apprentissage dans les exploitations
les cours théoriques très pointu
contribuer à faire de ces jeunes de
vrais professionnels de la terre un
savoir qui les conforte dans leur choix
de carrière
même si les manifestations
d'agriculteurs en colère ces derniers
mois les inquiète pas forcément des
doutes quand on voit qu'on ça fait trois
ans que ça va tuer
c'est difficile de vivre pour ses repas
on a forcément le doute qui avec des
années comme ça ça nous fait un peu peur
quand même qu'on va s'installer ces
conditions de s'installer avec une année
comme celle de cette année va se battre
jusqu'à une pression et les trois
stations à l'est est familiale depuis
cinq générations n'a pas envie que nous
on arrive et puis oui quelques années il
ya la clé sous la porte et les huissiers
qui sont là quoi bas dans la vie on n'a
rien sans rien donc il ya un moment il
faut se dire allez on se lance faut le
faire parce que si on se dit oh non je
ça me fait peur voilà qu'il ya personne
qui qu'avance quoi
et avancer quand on ne vient pas d'une
famille d'agriculteurs cela n'est pas
évident clémence est partie de ceux là
il n'empêche la vocation professionnelle
et là du fait de ne pas voir une famille
qui possède déjà une exploitation de
dollars censés partir de zéro bah ça m'a
fait un peu réfléchir je me suis dit
quand on a rien partir de rien en temps
de crise ce n'est pas facile j'aime ce
métier j'ai la volonté de faire ça donc
je suis motivé pour avoir ce diplôme
puis après bah enfin l'espoir fait vivre
donc pourquoi pas ici pour réussir à
réaliser ce rêve en fait reprendre
l'exploitation ce rêve
ils sont chaque jour davantage à la voir
comme clément plus de 30% des
installations sont réalisés en dehors du
cadre familial
un pourcentage qui a doublé en 25 ans
alors comment fait-on quand on doit
partir de rien pour répondre à cette
problématique
les chambres d'agriculture ont mis en
place un accompagnement personnalisé
[Musique]
les aides qui existent sont réservées
avec un diplôme agricole avec un bilan
de compétences qui permet de voir qu'on
a suffisamment d'expérience et de
compétences pour réussir
faut pas le prendre comme un comme une
contrainte mais comme plus sains une
assurance complémentaire pour pour
réussir et puis après la zézette c'est
essentiellement une dotation en capital
qu'on appelle dotation jeune agriculteur
qui permet aujourd'hui entre entre eux
entre dix et vingt mille euros en
moyenne quatorze mille euros
potentiellement plus en 2017 qui permet
de démarrer de d'avoir un apport d'avoir
une certaine sécurité
quand on démarre quoi selon les
syndicats d'agriculteurs
le principal problème de l'installation
des jeunes provient de l'espace agricole
qui diminue chaque seconde
26 mètres carrés de terres agricoles
disparaissent en france en cause la
pression de l'urbanisation et la course
à la rentabilité
le frein principal c'est d'avoir la
structure petites ou grandes qui est
nécessaire voilà je pense que nous les
dossiers qui aboutissent pas c'est
essentiellement pour des des problèmes
de mai
reese de foncer et même quand on a le
foncier les aides restent cependant
insuffisante pour certains jeunes
agriculteurs quelqu'un qui n'a pas
d'exploitation à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment très compliqué de
s'installer c'est quasi impossible
aimer quelqu'un qui a une exploitation
faut racheter toutes les parts de son
père et on a toujours des taxes venant
de l'état donc c'est vraiment des sommes
qui peuvent aller qui peut être colossal
donc ça peut être inquiétant mais bon on
se rassure en disant que c'est le plus
beau des métiers du mont houy
le financement la crise le manque de
foncier
les difficultés ne manquent pas pour les
futurs agriculteurs les chiffres de ces
dix dernières années nous montrent
qu'ils sont de moins en moins nombreux à
se lancer en 2005 ils étaient 2 141 à
s'installer en 2015
ils n'étaient plus que 188 pourtant
pendant notre enquête nous avons
rencontré une génération optimiste et
passionné pour qu'il y ait un avenir
sans paysans en france est
inenvisageable
[Musique]
dans l'agricole y aura toujours un
avenir parce que c'est quand même le
premier métier qui existaient et
puissant agriculture ya pas de vie
pensent qu'ils faisaient de plus en plus
de faire un échange entre le groupe et
pour être plus forte
après ça je prends mon cas partir de
rien pourquoi pas se mettant en
associant d'autres personnes pour
reprendre l'exploitation a traversé une
crise il faut qu'on arrive à en sortir
et il faut arriver à installer ces
jeunes c'est c'est pas un dehors c'est
une obligation pour nous agriculteurs